Karen Walker I thought I smelled Jin and
regret Everly lesle you look more like a
woman every time I see
you thank you you know I had to speak up
for you just now the ladies were saying
how sad and pathetic you are being all
alone here without Stanley but I
defended you I said she's a hophead
too well well
well
or maybe
not whyever Taren Walker just breaks my
heart that you don't have a partner for
the spotlight dance however will you
lead it without a partner Such a Pity a
bottle of rum can't
wals I am slapping you with a lawsuit
for defamation of character I was
hosting a Suare for the Republic party
on the flight deck of the Intrepid your
friend publicly insinuated that I was a
homosexual and well well
[Applause]
well hello
Karen I thought Walker Texas Ranger got
cancelled years ago because of old
age Mr Beverly Leslie here's your B-52
with one Ice Cube thank you sweetie I
thought your drink was a Blackberry
julip with a baby aspirin
Chaser I
switched wait a minute how do you know
that because come on come on come on
come on because I'm good at my job quit
busting my hump
lady what nothing honey I was just
looking at your
balls you're Stripes
right Karen Walker's sad and alone if I
weren't so compassionate I'd be laughing
like
this I heard Stan kicked you out of the
mans like a dried up old tumble weed but
I ever thought You' a blown all the way
down here are you just visiting my
section of the wall I'm here to buy a
dress to bury crystal in Ione mean I
think maybe you should wear men's
clothes
for Bev Bev honey come here you know
that I love you in my way and I know
that you loved crystal in your way so
now that she's out of the way
is there anything that I can do for you
well Karen it would really mean a lot to
me if you would attend Crystal's
memorial service tomorrow afternoon well
of course barely I wouldn't miss it and
Miss Adler why don't you join us oh no
no I I I couldn't intrude on on a day
that's so intimate and personal and
boring oh please it's not going to be
anything like that it's more like a
party celebration of her death life life
life so I'll see you both tomorrow
afternoon I'll be receiving from 5:30
till
6:30 boy that's got to be a long hour
for you oh I'm really going to enjoy
having roserio around the
Villa she even alphabetized my impostor
fragrances
yeah oops baby go
boom now you stop being such a tease it
is time for us to consummate this Union
I'm going to go put in a Magnum PI rerun
to get in the mood Grace would like to
say the traditional Jewish prayer for
the dead oh well how
delightful has that morphine kicked in
yet Karen I've always considered you a
dear friend that's a
yes I feel a burning need to share some
something intensely personal with you
but it's just so hard to say out loud oh
for God's sake don't cry you look like
Jeff sessions watching a black man
vote Aon this may come as a great shock
to
you but I'm a
homosexual that's it
what's your next bombshell Harvey
Weinstein isn't always a perfect
gentleman shrimp
queer pretty soon everywhere you look
you're going to see pickle shrimp well
well
well I walk in on a naked man a man in
his underpants and a woman who needs to
leave Beverly this isn't a good time and
I'm saying it could
be
now you know the plot of the homosexual
is a cause dear to my wife Crystal's
heart so I plan on taking her money and
purchasing that dinner for me and my
business associate
Beni Beverly I am so sorry I I don't
want to hear it I don't want to hear it
Miss Adler how dare you come into my
home and desecrate the day that I have
set aside to celebrate my wife's death
life why do I keep saying that that's it
I'm gay does the Hustler posing as your
business associate know he
suspects I am so sorry I missed the
ceremony but tell me this darling do
they still say till death do his part
when the Bride is a
vampire woo we
win take that you stupid
Giant but poor you your husband Stanley
Walker dumps you for a younger hoochie
mama who serves soft
potatoes he went from smashed to
mashed it's amazing my first time in a
gay bar and I see my first gay bar
five your first time you rang the
triangle well I better scadaddle
oh by the the way I heard what that man
said about Jack you are a true gentleman
if anybody ever called my friend an
idiot I hope I'd be as Brave as you
thank you Beverly how about a
gentleman's kid I'm not that brave Karen
I need you to help me come out to my
wife Crystal tonight would be a good
night to tell her but it's her 90th
birthday and I'm afraid the shock might
kill
her come to think of it tonight might be
the perfect night to tell her if it is
Karen Walker's little gay friend
where's your Olive skinned cohort don't
you homosexuals always travel in peirs
I'm not afraid to hit you you little
cup-sized
capot well bring it on big cheater M
[Laughter]
stealer get off of me tattoo get off of
me